[Music]
thank you guys
it's gonna be here at my home scam and I
support Andrew yang for president thank
you okay okay
I mean I'm part of the yank gang true
and proud you can call me a gangster you
guys can join me in Gangster it's
paradise I can't wait to the streets in
2020 I'm gonna go out of yank banging I
love a universal basic income I think if
everyone got $1,000 every month you guys
would be a lot more bearable to be
around there's some money's not playing
music in the subway I paid for it let's
get rid of poor people my payment
they're an annoying class we don't need
it oh the poor people who played
Bluetooth speaker music I allowed in
public I've ever cross paths with you
with each other they're like walking
around hey that's annoying wait a minute
my boy I am pretty logical and smart
I am safety of sexual I'm looking for a
woman who is intellectually stimulated
by the mental exercise of finding me
attractive woman is into puzzles holy
[ __ ]
[Music]
I don't like anime that much but anyone
who is sexually attracted to me is
really at animator that I was constantly
cosplaying can't stop won't stop I'm
always at comic-con I am on caves like
Oh Kiko get the wasabi I ate it up I got
a sushi restaurant so the some of my job
is the location
it's 15 bucks an hour and usually I
charge no age but you guys getting it
for free lucky you know he's gonna be I
just let stand there making Asian noises
every now and then but we're mostly
quiet but every know their discomfort
and anxiety it's permeating my
everything you know a lot of my Asian
friends make fun of me because I General
Tso's chicken so isn't that a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian yeah my favorite
movies very funny mark was like I used a
boarding to express my emotions I've
never needed a sport to do that I've
never been in the therapist I've been
like oh yeah by skateboarding sure how I
really feel
I feel like this right now my friend was
like why didn't even go to a therapist
they're just talking exactly what you
want to hear is that what you say to
your masseuse why don't you go to your
masseuse they're just touching you
exactly what you want to be touched
they better be
[Applause]